欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们这一章节我们来讲一下怎样去分析流量渠道
通过分析流量渠道来去提升我们不同流量渠道的流量
来实现我们整个店铺的流量增长
通过下面的流量参谋我们的各个板块来看清楚
我们各个渠道流量现状怎么样去布局我们的优质的渠道
现在我们看后台就是流量渠道里面会有流量来源
流量助手流量承接及去向这三大板块
那么这三大板块它的作用是什么
那么我们可以根据这三大板块的数据怎么样去判断
然后需要我们去做哪些优化调整来提升我们的店铺效果呢
我们一个板块一个板块的去看
第一个板块就是流量来源
这个流量来源的话我们可以看到我们的店铺的
所有的流量主要是在哪些板块是最多的
哪些板块是没有流量的
我们也可以知道我们店铺哪个流量局道看比比较大
它的转化率比较高
那么对于转化率高的我们是不是要重点关注和重点去提升
那么转化率低的或者是说流量少的
我们是不是要考虑这个局道还有没有一些操作方法能够拉升它的一个整体的流量来增加我们整个店铺的流量
第三个就是可以判断出我们店铺的流量主要是分布在VC端呢
还是在无限端呢他们的效果怎么样我们是不是就知道我们后期我们在产品详营业装修及加上我们推广的时候是不是会有更加侧重点
第四个就是针对不同的流量我们分别可以采用什么样的方法去提升结合我们之前学的方法去应用就能够非常有效的提升我们整个店铺的一个效果了
第四个板块就是流量助手这个板块流量助手我们可以知道现在的场景的热品是哪些我们同时也要知道它的入场规则
知道了它的规则我们才能去打造我们的产品进入这些场景去获取流量
同时也可以去通过这个板块挖掘一些市场比较热销的产品去发产品去推广来提升我们整个店铺的爆品量和直立品的数量
那么第二个就是这三大场景在我们店铺里面目前的流量效果怎么样
如果效果差我们应该怎么样去提升效果好的我们应该如何去保持或者是说放大它的流量效果
这些都能够通过数据来进行呈现我们一定要去知道这些场景的入场规则
才能够更有针对性的去选择产品去打造
第三个呢我们店铺里面的流量承接情况怎么样以及进我们店铺的板客他又会去到哪些店铺哪些产品
为什么我们留不住他们
所以说我们一定要对这些板块进行一个
详细的分析比如说第一个就是流量概要
我们要知道
我们店铺里面这几个很快的流量中还有哪些局道我们的流量是非常少的而且我们可以能够去做的
板块有哪些这里相当于一个查漏补缺去做一些被我们遗漏的事情也是有利于提升我们整个店铺的
第二个板块判断流失的这些客户去同行哪些店铺看看这些买家都喜欢什么样的款式
我们就可以针对性的去选品和优化产品了
第三个的话我们还可以参考他们这些平台的好产品去选择产品
进行推广等等一系列的操作都可以
接下来我们到后台去看一下
具体是怎么样的
首先我们打开流量参谋
流量参谋里面是第一个板块就是流量来源流量来源这里面会有很多个局道你看这里有非常多的局道
这里的所有的局道的流量相加相加就等于你店铺的总的流量
首先我们来看一下这里通常来说不要选择隐藏
我们能够看得更全数据更多更全
我们一般来说按周或者是按月来去看如果你需要按天分析的话那么你就直接按天就是说细致的分析那么可能会拆分到天去
看数据那么这里面的
所有的流量就是构成你整个店铺的总流量
那么这里每个流量的局道他都代表什么呢比如说这个搜索
我们把鼠标点击到这些问号里面这些问号里面
每个问号都给我们解释清楚了这些流量来自于哪里
那么我们一定要先了解这些局道他统计数据的维度
我们才知道为什么
做的不好我们需要从哪些维度去优化
比如说你从这个访客可以看出
有些局道是有数据的有些局道是没有数据的那么这个时候我们是不是
就知道
我们这些局道做的太差了
那么这些局道有些做的比较好的
是不是我们可以在这里去调整
看看我们还能够做哪些
操作来提升这些板块的流量
如果这些做得很好的那么我们就要
持续的保持
就可以了
另外一个就是看商机转化率
比如说
推荐局道的
转化率非常高但是呢
他的访客
非常少
我可能去
做一些推荐流量的
推广
来提升他的访客来增加他的整体的一个循环
跟Tm的总数量
另外一种情况
比如说
我的搜索局道做的访客
非常的多
但是他的商机转化率就很
巡盘还有Tm都是很少的
那么这种情况
我们从这个数据可以看出什么呢
说明我们的搜索局道方面的转化率低
是因为我们的
一个是可能是词的不精准
第二个是可能是产品跟买家不够匹配
所以这个时候呢
我们想要提升我们的搜索局道的一个
转化率是不是就要继分到你的产品维度
去找问题
产品维度里面会有一些词的问题
国家的问题是不精准的问题
价格起定量等问题是不是更加细分维度
这里通过这个局道就是局道
细分到产品产品细分到词国家价格起定量
是不是一个非常完整的链路
我们这里举个案例吧
比如说有些人他的店铺
1月份跟2月份3月份
在3月份的时候他的搜索流量暴跌了是吧
为什么他会暴跌呢
你就要去找到当前暴跌的产品
你本来这个搜索局道在暴跌了
那么说明你原来的好产品的数据一定是在下降的
因为这些局道是靠产品数据积累的
那么产品下降了
你就去看爆款产品
爆款产品就往这个细分维度看
词
他排名是不是变差了
国家是不是不精准了
或者是说有曝光量有点击的词变少了
另外一个就是你的国家
这些爆品的国家
访客都不精准了
所以说就会导致他的一个
转化率会很低
可能这些访客也在下降
所以我们通过这些局道
其实都能够分析出很多的问题
最终每一个局道反馈的问题
我们都可以衍生到是产品的问题
产品的问题我们就可以细分维度
然后再到
自动车这些团
是不是完整的一条列路
先是局道
局道再到
细分到产品
产品里面有词
有这些数据
这些数据又可能是自动车里面的
是不是我们可以去调整这些自动车里面的具体的指标
是不是就可以反过来
就相当于对这个局道进行优化了
比如说这些转化率那么我们就要去看对应的板块
本身你已经知道它的入场规则了
你在针对我们店铺里面
还有哪些操作可以让我们的产品
进入这些维度我们就去对那些产品进行提升就可以了
那么这个板块就是流量来源
通过流量来源的这些
数据维度可以帮助我们反馈很多问题在针对性的去找到
对应的产品产品在细节上面去分析
在进行优化就可以得到改善了
第2个板块呢就是流量助手这个板块
我们就不展开详细讲了
你只要按照我们之前的思路去
学习去应用就可以了
当然这里有一个板块
这个板块就是买家画像可以参考一下
参考就可以了
不一定是说跟这个完全一模一样
第3个板块就是流量承接集趣向
首先我们来看一下他的这里是全部流量
全部流量这里面有这些流量构成
那么这些流量里面构成就有这些细分你点一下他
就有细分这些我们没有必要去
使记因为
我们只需要知道这些板块我们哪个能做要去进行操作就可以了
接下来就是
流量的承接
比如说
这里有我的产品
你可以看到他的这些产品可以去进行一个优化就可以了
根据这些筛选一些产品进行优化就可以了
行业的优品您去看一下
可以参考
这个行业的优品去选品之类的都可以了
如果你不看这个板块的话
你看这里有个
广告画像也可以去看一下
买家参谋这里也可以去看一下
其实跟这个板块有点相关的他的思路大致是一样的
那么在接下来这个板块你的产品看了你的店铺了
去向
这些同行的店铺的都是哪些产品你要去看一下
为什么他去这些产品你去把这些产品
搜索出来看一下跟你们对比一下有什么差距
有什么不一样
地域偏好就是这些人都是哪些国家的比如说
你们本身国家的就是美国的这些客户
如果是
这些占比都是你们目标国家比较多的那么说明你的这个访客人群还是比较精准的
以及类目偏好
比如说这些类目如果搜索你们进你们店铺的这些类目跟你们的相关度比较低或者是说
排序跟你们
主营的不一样比如说你做卫衣的
那么这里的很多客户都是先
找到的是群职的那么这可能就跟你们的
相关度就会偏低一点
就会导致你整体的一个许盘转化就会偏低了
因为相关性越高他的转化会越好
而且他精准度越高
那么这个产品的偏好的话你大概了解就可以了
因为这个板块也是跟其他板块有一些相似的
所以说这里这些通常来说都是了解就可以了
这些没有必要是说
你非要去记住这些板块
那么这个就是我们
关于
流量
渠道
以及
如何去通过数据分析找到哪些可以提升的渠道
再去
针对性的去操作就可以了
那么我们前面讲了很多
具体的方法了
我们只需要在这个板块学会如何去分析如何去判断数据就可以了
这个板块主要用于
发掘一些数据去判断店铺效果
再根据我们之前所学的那些方法对应操作就可以了